my talk at the table is a new study of  raiding the environmental impact of 57  000 foods british scientists i don't  know  how the foods impact greenhouse gas  emissions land use and water by using  these impact scores the foods rated the  worst on the list were beef and lamb  nuts and dried fruit and coffee for all  you coffee drinkers i know that's not  good news plant-based meat alternatives  did better  and on the flip side squash fizzy drinks  like colas and sports energy drinks they  were found to be least harmful to the  environment so just keep in mind while  you're eating i know we're talking a lot  of food on the show today but i want you  to keep in mind tony while you're making  all of those fancy pizzas i'm keeping in  mind how it tastes what it's doing to my  body i mean trying to incorporate what  it's doing to the earth at the same time  it's a lot of incorporating man versus  food over here that's a lot squash pizza  yeah exactly exactly all right